DOES RACISM EXIST IN THE ANIMAL
KINGDOM?
>> TRIBALISM EXISTS IN THE
ANIMAL KINGDOM.
THIS IS WHAT I THINK IS AT THE
BASE OF THIS.
HAVE WE TALKED ABOUT ULTRAVIOLET
LIGHT?
>> Larry: NO.
YOU'RE GOING TO JUMP ON THIS.
EVERYBODY IS FROM EAST AFRICA
I HAD THE TESTS RUN, I'M PARTLY
BANTU
YOU MIGRATE INTO MESOPOTAMIA,
TIGRIS AND THE EUPHRATES
YOU HAVE TO HAVE THE BREAKING
DOWN OF YOUR
FOLIC ACID.
THEN MIGRATE ACROSS ASIA,
RAISING WHEAT, EATING STUFF,
THEN THE ICE AGE, ALL THE STUFF
IS FROZEN IN THE MOUNTAINS, YOU
CAN WALK TO SARAH PALIN'S FUTURE
HOUSE, AND THEN YOU COME DOWN
THE WEST COAST --
>> Larry: I FEEL RACISM IS
ABOUT TO START.
I FEEL LIKE IT'S STARTING.
>> IT'S STARTED, BECAUSE YOU'VE
GOT THESE TRIBES AND THEY HAVE
DIFFERENT SKIN COLOR AS A RESULT
OF ULTRAVIOLET LIGHT.
NOW, YOU CAN RUN THIS TEST,
LARRY.
>> Larry: WHAT IS THE TEST?
IF A GUY FROM NORWAY, ONE OF
MY PEOPLE --
>> Larry: YEAH.
-- HAS AN INTERACTION, CAN WE
SAY INTERACTION ON TELEVISION?
>> Larry: WE'RE ON BASIC
CABLE.
WITH A WOMAN FROM ZIMBABWE, ALL
YOU'RE GOING TO GET IS A HUMAN,
YOU WON'T GET SOME OTHER NEW
THING.
>> Larry: YOU'RE GOING TO GET
SOME GOOD HAIR, TOO.
THAT'S A JOKE.
>> WE'RE ALL THE SAME THING
FROM A SCIENTIFIC STANDPOINT, SO
THERE'S NO SUCH THING AS RACE
BUT THERE IS SUCH A THING AS
TRIBALISM.
>> Larry: WHEN A GUY FROM NORWAY
HAS SEX WITH AN
AFRICAN WOMAN, RACISM IS OVER.
THAT'S WHAT YOU SAID, RIGHT?
>> YOU GOT IT.